We believe that he gave life to the dead
with God's permission. We believe that
he healed those born blind and lepers
with God's permission.
Okay. Do you believe in his religion?
That's what I'm completing. If Christian
means following the teachings of Jesus
Christ peace be upon him, we Muslims are
more Christian the Christian themselves.
You know Jesus Christ is mentioned in
the gospel. He was circumcised on the
eth day. Are all the Christians
circumcised?
Yeah, they're circumcised.
What? Pardon? Pardon? No. Sorry. Pardon?
Partly.
Pardon? I'm saying Jesus Christ peace be
upon them was circumcised on the eighth
day. Mhm. The Bible says that. Correct.
Yeah. Are the Christians circumcised?
Yes. Yes. Yeah.
Where you from? Which part of the world
are you in Kenya? All the Christians are
circumcised.
They're saying no they know better than
you.
There are few Christians who are
circumcised. Majority are not. As far as
Islam is concerned, almost
all are circumcised. So who is a better
Christian? The Muslims or the so-called
Christian? It's mentioned in the Bible.
You should not have poke. Gospel of Luke
chapter number 11 verse number 7. In the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 14
verse number 8. The Christian they have
poke or not? Most of the
Christian most of the Christians have
poke or not. Yeah.
Are they following the teachings of
Jesus Christ or not?
Actually, I don't know. They're not
following. But who's more Christian? The
Muslims or the Christian? Yeah.
Muslims. It's mentioned in the Bible in
the book of Ephesians 5 verse number 18.
Thou shalt not be drunk with wine.
Do most of the Christians have alcohol
or
not? Most of the Christians have alcohol
not? Most of the Christian do they have
alcohol or not?
Don't know. Actually, I think there is a
problem with their speaker. I don't want
to I don't hear you. I saw there's
problem in my speaker. Now there problem
in your speaker. That's difficult.
Everyone is understanding. My speaker
has problem to the Christians. Most of
the Christian do they have alcohol or
not? Wine.
Wine. Do they drink wine or not? They
do. So are they following the Bible or
not? They follow the Bible. Bible says
in the book of Ephesians 5 verse number
18, don't be drunk with
wine. Are they following or going
against the
Bible? Still they follow the Bible.
Sorry, they follow the Bible still.
You know there's a book called as book
of Ephesus 5 verse number 18. Mhm. Do
you have the Bible with you? I don't
have. We have with you. No. It says
don't be drunk with wine. So are they
following? Are they going against the
Bible? Anyway, I will continue. I think
we cannot hear me. We cannot waste the
time. So if Christian means the person
who follows the teachings of Jesus, true
teachings of Jesus Christ, not the
teaching of the church, then we Muslims
are more Christian than the Christian
themselves. So if you truly
study the Bible and the Quran both are
same. But if you don't know how to study
and you're misguided by the teachings of
the church, then there's a difference of
chalk and cheese.
Otherwise, if you truly follow the
teachings of Jesus Christ, peace be upon
him, you'll have to follow the Quran.
There is no
option. He has been prophesized many
times. I'm going to speak day after
tomorrow. And in Tanzania, I'm giving a
talk similarities between Islam and
Christianity. No problem. So, if you
truly read the teachings of both Jesus
and Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
the major teaching is the same. In
minute of course, Prophet Muhammad
bought a lot of new laws peace be upon
him. But Jesus did not. Jesus Christ did
not bring any new law. So in terms of
overall message is the same. In terms of
detail, Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him because he was the final messenger
and Quran because it was the final
message has more details and the
religion got completed after the Quran
was revealed not at the time of Jesus
peace be upon him. So between the two if
you have to follow you have to follow
the Quran and prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. Hope that answers the
question. Okay.